every week we also like to take a look
at the biggest stories in the world of
show business the entertainment news
headlines in a section we call the HBO
headlines no bigger star in the
headlines this week then Justin Bieber
himself we've been featuring him every
week no without trust me we all in this
room hate him there's no need to voice
your disapproval we've been talking
about him so much so we've talked about
the fact that we need a jingle or this
happen well the fans have gone nuts the
listeners have gone crazy and been
sending in a ton of jingles I've sifted
through most them I came to these three
who so we're gonna take a listen to a
couple of them and see what you think
here's the first one from Jim Laskowski
he he wrote this one
[Music]
yeah that's it
maybe a little long for long so No let
me fix this one from Buzz Compton Buzz
Compton from Germany yeah I'm very hip
over yeah yeah yeah I am best Compton
and everybody I'm very cool here with
Germany y'all need to be pissed of all
the bunch that's right cuz my name is
buzz I'm like one of the American
astronaut you know but this straight
that have copious right and and turn me
right but you know the name come to make
you think here's buzz Compton's jingle
for Bieber that's it
you miss it while you're being rude
laughing in Germany that's what happened
can we replay that one for people who
are rude and laughing at Germany James
[Music]
brevity being the soul of wit man that's
the strong contenders yeah and rich
Williams from London and Birmingham in
the UK he said it would be great under
who's this in the pop scrotums news
section never work on the Bieber the
pops pop scrotum here's here's riches
[Music]
[Applause]
I take the people of spoken man as the
winner right there winner winner chicken
dinner
yeah it's as if the Cure did a jingle
for [ __ ] Brits why are they so much
cooler than us it's the accent you can
whip a contact the end and it says
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]